David: And then the recordings are going to be used. Just to make sure we've captured all your opinions accurately after we complete the analysis. The recordings are destroyed, and none of your comments will be attributed to you directly.
David: so I have started recording, and I'd like to confirm. Are you comfortable if I record the screen and audio.
Justin Warren: Sure.
David: Great.
David: Okay? So now we can actually get into it. So Justin, could you tell me a little bit about your role at the Va,
David: yeah, just to start there.
Justin Warren: Sure, I work in office of Vha digital media which is within the office of Vha communications. Our primary role is helping manage the websites for our organization, which include the drupal vamc
Justin Warren: websites for all
Justin Warren: all the hospitals in the nation.
David: Okay, so the Jupal Bamc sites for the whole nation. Okay, that's a that's a lot. And
David: so how often are you really using Cms to do things like uploading images.
Justin Warren: Not
Justin Warren: often.
Justin Warren: I just recently had to do it
Justin Warren: a candid, a campaign landing page. So
Justin Warren: I probably do it
Justin Warren: maybe a few times a year.
David: Okay a few times a year and campaign landing pages is that the the main one that you're typically
David: working on? Is it? Are there other pages that you find yourself uploading images to.
Justin Warren: It's usually a campaign landing page. What I would upload image to.
David: Okay, typically campaign. Great.
David: so could you kind of talk about that general workflow for uploading an image?
David: So yeah, kind of like with, yeah, how how you get the image from start to finish.
Justin Warren: Yeah, usually
Justin Warren: I will get the images from whoever's the customer, whoever's requesting a particular page.
Justin Warren: So I'll have like a set of images of probably 5 or 6 images.
Justin Warren: And typically, I will just save into my desktop and then go through the steps
Justin Warren: and within drupal to
Justin Warren: get it in the live media library and then upload it to the page.
David: And then, typically in that workflow, do you find yourself?
David: using? I I'm I'm I'm a little less familiar with the campaign specific uploader. But do you upload the images all to the media library 1st and then grab them? Or it does the campaign page allow you to just upload the images.
David: and they're also going to the media library at that time.
Justin Warren: But if I'm not mistake, you have to upload it to the media library first.st
David: You have to upload to the media library first.st Okay?
David: Got it? Got it? So you're receiving the images? Do you find yourself ever editing or cropping those images, or doing adjustments to them before you're uploading them.
Justin Warren: Some of them, because I know there's certain
Justin Warren: dimensions you can choose from. So if depending on what the image is, if it's
Justin Warren: like completely.
Justin Warren: If the image is like too large or it like doesn't fit.
Justin Warren: I may have to
Justin Warren: adjust it, but what I I think what I end up doing is just choosing the right.
Justin Warren: I guess, dimension that are
Justin Warren: within the options. We have
Justin Warren: to kind of make the best fit.
David: Hmm.
David: okay, so are there specific dimensions that the campaign requires you to upload the images in.
Justin Warren: No, I think I think it gave me the options, for, like a I can't remember the exact ratios of each one.
Justin Warren: But it gave me some options.
David: Gave you some options. Okay?
David: And are you always finding yourself like getting new images and uploading them to the media library? Or are you ever reusing images from the media library that you've already, maybe have uploaded.
Justin Warren: I have not had to reuse anything.
David: Okay.
David: So when you're putting images into the media library, it's really just for that one time.
Justin Warren: Yeah.
David: To get it in there, so you can use it. But you're not referring back to them at at later times.
Justin Warren: No, I haven't had to do that.
David: Okay.
David: great, great, great, great, great.
David: Okay. So
David: kind of getting started.
David: could you please share your screen with me? And we're gonna
David: And maybe you can do this after you log in. So it's not all recorded. But I'd love for you to open your cms
David: and from there we're gonna kind of just see you go through that typical workflow of a campaign image
David: uploading a campaign image.
Justin Warren: Gotcha.
David: So yeah, feel free to get on there before you start sharing, or whatever. Maybe you're already on there.
Justin Warren: Got mutes.
Justin Warren: Hmm!
Justin Warren: Access to not
Justin Warren: let me try another browser.
David: Open.
David: and I'm curious. Have you ever uploaded an event?
David: Events, or anything like that
David: familiar with.
Justin Warren: I'm familiar with presence. I have not
Justin Warren: had to upload an event.
David: Okay.
David: And if this isn't
David: working oh, oh, you're right good.
David: I do have a plan. B, just in case
David: think we got it.
Justin Warren: Right.
David: Okay, so we're here.
David: so yeah, I would say, for this prompt
David: imagine that you're creating a new campaign.
David: And you'd like to add in a photo. So I'd like you to kind of walk through that process of
David: going to the campaign creating a new one. And you can really skip over the bits that are more specific for the campaign. And we can just focus on that photo aspect
David: and feel free to take
David: you. I can send you a photo if you have a random photo on your desktop. That's also fine, whatever you'd like. But I'd love just to kind of watch. You kind of go through that process.
Justin Warren: Okay.
David: Okay, so and then, as you're kind of going through this, if you could kind of think aloud. So.
Justin Warren: If you're thinking.
David: Clicking something, or you're a little confused, just kind of vocalize that, too. It really helps with
David: this kind of research.
Justin Warren: Gotcha.
Justin Warren: So yeah, I usually start with content
Justin Warren: media and media image.
David: Okay.
Justin Warren: Let's see.
Justin Warren: See, I think I got some random photos online
Justin Warren: start.
Justin Warren: So I'm just renaming a random photo.
David: Yeah, sure. Sure.
Justin Warren: Description.
Justin Warren: I.
Justin Warren: That's good.
Justin Warren: see
Justin Warren: type the description in type, the name in.
David: Yeah, let's can we take one second and and pause for a second?
David: So 1st of all, with the family photo that you entered the for the name category. Could you kind of tell me
David: why you pick that name, and where that name shows up.
Justin Warren: The photo the random photo is is gonna be a picture of my family.
David: Okay.
Justin Warren: Mean family photo.
Justin Warren: yeah, typically all the name is gonna correspond to the whatever the picture is.
Justin Warren: Then same with the description.
Justin Warren: yeah, I only follow from Christmas, so
Justin Warren: does it. I usually
Justin Warren: I'm pretty succinct with my words, so I won't. I don't say
Justin Warren: to worry about the character limit.
David: Got it. And then the description,
David: do you always find yourself inputting a description?
David: Typically
David: just as it's a non. I I bring this up because it! It doesn't have one of those little red
David: asterisk that's next to it.
Justin Warren: I think.
Justin Warren: Naturally, I just put a description in
Justin Warren: I didn't even like recognize that it was not a required field.
David: Gotcha? And where does the description
David: go, or how is it used.
Justin Warren: Did this
Justin Warren: describe the photo and
Justin Warren: basically give
Justin Warren: more information than the title or the name of the photo.
Justin Warren: I could see an instance where there's
Justin Warren: multiple photos from an event. So you wanna kinda use description to separate it
Justin Warren: separated.
David: Okay?
David: Great. Yeah. Feel free to carry on.
David: Yeah, I'm seeing you clicking on that.
David: yeah.
David: Could you tell me? Was was that information there useful for you? Are you familiar with that.
Justin Warren: Yeah, I am familiar, because this is a
Justin Warren: section 5, 0, 8.
Justin Warren: Practice as far as having
Justin Warren: good all text. I use it as a reminder.
Justin Warren: They're not.
Justin Warren: I have. Sometimes I haven't used an image of a photo of. So I it's good to look at it.
David: Snapcha.
Justin Warren: I use that as a to not use those phrases.
Justin Warren: yeah.
Justin Warren: these are always good reminders.
David: So for the crop image, I'm curious about this one.
David: Yes.
David: yeah. Government.
Justin Warren: I'm sorry.
David: Oh, no! Feel free. I'm not here.
Justin Warren: This is what I was referring to earlier. I can't remember all the ratios. So
Justin Warren: oh, yeah.
Justin Warren: did not take my advice. Thank you for the red screen.
Justin Warren: I.
Justin Warren: This is where I was referring to.
Justin Warren: and I'll say it has different like aspect ratios.
Justin Warren: and depending on the photo.
Justin Warren: We may only need certain parts of the photo.
Justin Warren: So I would like look through to see if any of these aspect ratios work.
Justin Warren: Judging by
Justin Warren: my photo.
Justin Warren: it's there. I don't think I need to crop it in this way.
David: Okay.
Justin Warren: I. It is something. When I did upload a photo
Justin Warren: that I looked at just to kind of
Justin Warren: see if it would, you know, enhance or help me in any way.
David: So which one will you pick.
Justin Warren: I guess. Do I have to do that.
David: Oh, I'm not sure.
David: What do you think?
Justin Warren: I I didn't think so. I guess I'll find out once. I say, if it rejects me or not, I don't
Justin Warren: makes sense.
David: Haven't.
Justin Warren: As far as section.
Justin Warren: Do you care where I save it to.
David: somewhere, you would, wherever you would put your campaigns.
Justin Warren: Yeah.
David: And then we don't actually have to go through and press save just because I yeah, this is broad.
Justin Warren: okay, so yeah, I would
Justin Warren: choose there and then.
Justin Warren: And I was safe.
David: Got it.
David: Okay?
David: So
David: yeah, we would imagine you click, save. And then it would be up in the media library.
David: Now, could we kind of go into that campaign and and really see how you would like get that picture from the media library. So we yeah, let's just pretend the pictures up here.
Justin Warren: Okay.
Justin Warren: so for campaigns.
Justin Warren: see?
Justin Warren: Actually, pull mine up.
Justin Warren: Actually
Justin Warren: working on.
David: So
David: yeah, perfect. We see an image here.
David: would we? Would you be
David: comfortable? Kind of like pressing the X and and just re uploading the specific picture.
Justin Warren: Yes.
Justin Warren: trying to make sure I can remember where to find.
Justin Warren: That's fine.
Justin Warren: Well, it should still be in the library, so.
David: Okay, perfect. Yeah. Just holding hands. Dot Png. So we don't forget.
Justin Warren: You know.
David: Correct that now.
Justin Warren: See.
Justin Warren: let's filter. So if I want to find this.
Justin Warren: I would search
Justin Warren: campaign landing
Justin Warren: me. So
Justin Warren: let's do that.
Justin Warren: See if it comes up there it is.
David: There it is!
Justin Warren: Yeah.
David: Okay, fantastic. Okay, so let's take a second
David: here. When you uploaded that image the 1st time. Right?
David: But
David: thinking about ratios, I'm reading here, your image will be displayed at a 1 to one aspect. Ratio.
David: Was that an aspect ratio that you set for this description, holding hands image
David: when you uploaded it?
David: Or is it auto doing that? I'm I'm I'm not sure.
Justin Warren: I
Justin Warren: make sure? I answer
Justin Warren: brushing.
Justin Warren: I just took the image that was given to me and then just uploaded it.
Justin Warren: and I might have. I can't remember. If I had to crop it or not, I might have might have had to.
David: Got it.
Justin Warren: And I didn't. That that was the extent of it. I didn't do anything to the photo, or
Justin Warren: and I think this one to one aspect is set as far as this template is, so
Justin Warren: it wasn't my choice to go one to one, but.
David: God.
Justin Warren: It's a lot of work.
David: Got it. Got it?
David: Okay?
David: Then one other question. When we're back on that page. So if you clicked X
David: and you were back on that page, and it said, Add or select media.
David: do you ever find yourself adding media directly through that kind of mo like pop up, or are you always adding your media to the mail media library first.st
Justin Warren: The
Justin Warren: I probably did both, I think, when I was working on this I probably did both. I probably opted in, and some were dropped in and some were
Justin Warren: media library.
David: Got it.
David: Okay?
David: Fantastic. Okay, so how would you say that overall experience was for you of kind of uploading the picture.
David: getting it in there making sure the ratios look good.
David: Yeah, what what did you like
David: about that process?
Justin Warren: I like the the ability to drag and drop.
Justin Warren: That makes easier like. Well, you know, few less steps.
Justin Warren: Alright.
Justin Warren: If I remember correctly the
Justin Warren: if I had to crop it.
Justin Warren: I like the fact it gives you options.
Justin Warren: you know. It makes it pretty. Makes it easier as far as
Justin Warren: trying to
Justin Warren: make it
Justin Warren: work. So you know, it'll fit the template.
David: You'll fit the template.
David: Gotcha
David: what if anything, did you not like so much about the process.
Justin Warren: I don't think there's anything I dislike. If there were. Well, if
Justin Warren: if there was a situation where
Justin Warren: the photo didn't fit.
Justin Warren: Or it distorted the photo.
Justin Warren: and that'd be something I would decide.
David: Got it. Yeah.
David: kind of thinking about. You know your experience with just the Internet, and like uploading things on other websites.
David: Is this
David: similar, or or are very different to say, like uploading a picture to a social media or an email, or something.
Justin Warren: Right.
Justin Warren: I would say it's similar.
Justin Warren: I would say similar. I know.
Justin Warren: you know, with social media is mostly done on phones.
Justin Warren: I don't think that social media you can
Justin Warren: drag and drop.
Justin Warren: maybe, but.
David: You like the drag and drop. That's great.
Justin Warren: Yeah, a lot of times I'm I'm gonna probably save it on my desktop. The.
David: Oh, okay, it's always on your desktop. So like that, drag and drop is really helpful for you.
Justin Warren: Yeah.
David: Fantastic
David: alright. Well, thank you. And now let's move on to the next
David: part of this.
David: So I'm going to now share with you a potential redesign of an image upload system.
David: just for a little bit of context. It is looking a little bit more like events. But I think, after seeing your campaign page, they're they are very similar. So
David: hopefully, nothing should be too
David: new so I'm gonna go ahead and share a link with you.
David: See, hopefully, this works.
David: Wait. Oh, not to wait. You hear me.
David: and I just sent it on zoom chat.
Justin Warren: See.
David: Fantastic and on the left side, or I, before we even jump into that. This is this is what it currently looks like, and you can see that it's it's pretty similar to the campaign, right like
David: where it should be listed. In that image event.
David: Section, I think, has a lot of similarities is, that is that all right?
Justin Warren: Yes.
David: Okay.
David: great. So let's go ahead and click proposed flow in the left side.
Justin Warren: Okay.
David: And
David: so now let's just go through the prompt. And again you're doing such a great job kind of explaining to me as you're clicking through as you're thinking about it. Just keep that up.
David: So imagine that you have started to create a new event for veterans.
David: You've entered the date where the location's happening. It's already listed in there, and now it's time to upload an image.
David: So please show me how you would go ahead and do that.
Justin Warren: Okay.
David: It was for the some coffee hour event that's being held in New York.
David: That's the kind of context there that we put.
Justin Warren: See, I probably start with upload image.
Justin Warren: and I'd probably drag over.
David: They dragged out.
Justin Warren: Yeah.
David: Okay, cool, cool. What? You could. Also, yeah, could you? Kind of yeah, the drag and drop thing. We haven't figured out quite well in prototyping yet. But say, say, you wanted to upload an image.
Justin Warren: Go back.
Justin Warren: upload an image, I will.
Justin Warren: more likely saving it to my desktop. So.
David: Okay, it would be on your desktop. Sure. Yeah, if you go ahead and click the event image, it should just kind of.
Justin Warren: Okay.
David: But in.
Justin Warren: Yeah
Justin Warren: refrain.
Justin Warren: I was trying to move it to.
David: Yeah, this is the prototype. So certain things won't work exactly as it would in dev. But like, just to kind of give you the idea of like.
David: alright, you uploaded the picture.
David: And now, yeah, kind of
David: tell me what this like page is doing like what? Based on the context of the the title and the the subtitle. What is this page for?
Justin Warren: This page is for advertising event. I think it was a coffee
Justin Warren: hour.
Justin Warren: you know, a town hall or something like that.
Justin Warren: right? This is to advertise the veterans to get people to show up to that event.
David: And then this, this specific page, we're looking at.
Justin Warren: Oh, this is a
Justin Warren: the image
Justin Warren: that will be displayed
Justin Warren: for the event.
Justin Warren: So this is what people will see like, I think when you click on events, they'll see this. I guess
Justin Warren: this image
Justin Warren: to the kind of
Justin Warren: kind of be the
Justin Warren: title picture for the event. Some people, yeah, yeah.
David: Yeah, feel, free to keep going.
Justin Warren: In, yeah.
Justin Warren: and add context.
Justin Warren: yeah, the section will be Bronx.
David: Amazing.
Justin Warren: And then you would
Justin Warren: put in your full description of the event.
David: Yeah.
David: yeah, so yeah, you just uploaded an image
David: to the event.
David: And you could kind of also imagine it to a campaign. That same exact process. The other process we can do if you go ahead and click X
David: there.
David: or sorry the X on the photo.
Justin Warren: Oh.
Justin Warren: yeah.
David: I'm curious about this other one select image from media library. What? What do you are? Yeah. What are you expecting? What is the difference between add media and select image from media library.
Justin Warren: Add me to be adding something
Justin Warren: new or something not in the media library. The media library is what's already been
Justin Warren: was already been put into
Justin Warren: that particular sections. Media library, the images they've used before.
David: Yeah.
David: So
David: here, let's also imagine that you're like looking for a photo the same way you would. Normally, I put in some parameters, because this is a prototypes. But if you click on file name and it should kind of interact with the example.
Justin Warren: Select image. Yeah, we'll select from the Bronx
Justin Warren: the file name.
Justin Warren: Oh, if you were searching so if I was searching for it.
Justin Warren: if I knew what I was looking. The name.
Justin Warren: I think, more probably search through the photos before.
David: Oh, oh, yeah, this is yeah. This is kind of similar to you looking for that holding hands image
David: from from that, from our.
Justin Warren: I mean.
Justin Warren: oh, and I'll let you click.
Justin Warren: I'll let you click that.
Justin Warren: Yeah.
Justin Warren: So yeah, I would either search by the file name and apply the filter.
Justin Warren: But if it's not a lot of photos.
Justin Warren: I would just look at the different photos.
David: You would just go through the photos, got it.
Justin Warren: With and then section.
Justin Warren: obviously depend on where you are. You just add your particular medical center
Justin Warren: sorting news first.st That's good, too, because cases are recently used one.
Justin Warren: So yeah, after our after I picked the phone, I would just continue.
Justin Warren: crop it. The way I need this particular aspect isn't great for this photo. This particular. I wish we had a different option.
David: Yeah, tell me a little bit more about the different options.
Justin Warren: Yeah, like
Justin Warren: this photo, you would want the whole, almost the entire image in there. And this is only gonna let you get, you know the 7 2 aspect ratio. So.
David: Yeah. And I'm curious. Why do you think?
David: Well, yeah.
David: thinking about like how, for example, we had the one to one for a campaign
David: event images
David: has the 7 to 2 by 2.
David: So I'm just kind of curious. Why, what's the difference between this experience and the previous like one that we went through
David: where we gave you the choices.
Justin Warren: Well, here, you don't get a choice.
Justin Warren: and you're kind of
Justin Warren: stuck with this particular aspect.
Justin Warren: And it worked. It's fine, like with the other photo. It worked.
Justin Warren: But this particular photo it won't.
Justin Warren: And there's
Justin Warren: there's a lot there's a way to
Justin Warren: for the system to adjust the photo itself to kind of make it fit. You just can only take a piece of
Justin Warren: the photo to fit the aspect ratio.
David: so if you go ahead and click the photo, it'll just do a little quick recrop for you
David: kind of show you how how you might be moving.
David: Now, if it says that all event images must have a 7 to 2 aspect ratio. That's kind of like imposed by dev
David: like if we, what would happen if we
David: in like a so in like the current version.
David: it also has a 7 to 2 aspect ratio for events.
David: What would happen if I was to put in a 1 by one or a square and upload that.
Justin Warren: You're asking me. What if you.
David: You think would happen? Yeah.
David: or what would you? What would you expect to happen.
Justin Warren: If this aspect ratio could be one to one.
David: If you uploaded a different sized aspect ratio than the required one.
Justin Warren: Oh, it will either cut it off or not.
Justin Warren: Save so you can publish.
Justin Warren: Would do one of those 2, but it wouldn't. You would get the desired outcome. You were probably looking for.
David: Got it. So what do you based on and on kind of like?
David: If you uploaded the image with the wrong crop size, it might not work.
David: What do you think about
David: this updated version kind of imposing the crop size to ensure that the photo uploads properly.
Justin Warren: I think it's good that it will do that, so you can
Justin Warren: at least go through, get through the steps.
Justin Warren: I think I have probably more issue with it, only allowing 7, 2.
Justin Warren: What
Justin Warren: if it'll get me through the steps?
Justin Warren: I think that'll work.
Justin Warren: and that's because most of the time.
Justin Warren: like myself, for when I have to do things, or I'm sure editors that would do this as well as
Justin Warren: is
Justin Warren: you being told to put this up
Justin Warren: and to do it now, so the faster you can get through these things the better it is.
David: I gotcha. Yeah.
David: Okay.
David: great. So yeah, if you go ahead and continue.
Justin Warren: Yeah. So the
Justin Warren: images are
Justin Warren: keeping missions coming.
Justin Warren: All text is in there section in there. So I would just save and upload.
Justin Warren: Then write my event description.
David: You're done. Yeah.
Justin Warren: And be done.
David: So, yeah, now that we kind of walk through that whole new process, the proposed flow.
David: what stands out to you about that new design?
Justin Warren: I guess when you can move the
Justin Warren: the automatic
Justin Warren: aspect ratio
Justin Warren: fitting part. Yeah, I will say that
Justin Warren: participants, huh!
David: Yeah. Is there anything else that stood stood out to you
David: in terms of
David: you know the process.
Justin Warren: think you said
Justin Warren: you can drag and drag a photo over.
Justin Warren: rather open the media library. So
Justin Warren: that's also something that stands out to me. That's that's a big plus
Justin Warren: funny.
David: So yeah, so with this version, you'll be more comfortable just uploading your images directly and campaign rather than uploading them to media library and then having to come back
David: that right.
Justin Warren: Right.
David: Okay.
David: did any of the new features help you upload your images more efficiently.
Justin Warren: That aspect ratio feature
Justin Warren: like I was saying it would
Justin Warren: rather than
Justin Warren: you manually trying to.
Justin Warren: you know. Figure it out.
Justin Warren: It's the right, is it? Kinda does it for you so it'll save some time.
David: Hello!
David: And then was finding your image any easier or harder, or about the same with with the with the new version compared to the older version.
Justin Warren: By an image within
Justin Warren: the.
David: I mean your image that's in the like media library. Yeah.
Justin Warren: I'm not sure cause I don't remember.
Justin Warren: Wait! What was the old way? Just.
David: Oh, yeah, we can do a quick recap if you well, if you go to current flow on the left.
David: This is how it is at the moment, and this should be matching with campaign version right now.
Justin Warren: So you would add
Justin Warren: also upload them.
David: So, yeah, this is the the current process that maybe you should. You're familiar with.
Justin Warren: Description.
Justin Warren: That's politics.
Justin Warren: then you have to choose which.
Justin Warren: Say
David: Oh, yeah, only only 2 of them were.
Justin Warren: Okay.
David: Yeah.
Justin Warren: Alright.
Justin Warren: I can choose 7, 2, or 2 to one.
Justin Warren: Is that.
David: You you can. Now the question is.
David: will it work.
Justin Warren: Gotcha.
Justin Warren: So okay.
David: So in the current system you're you will have these options.
David: But the question is, for example, with events, the required image ratio is 7 to 2.
Justin Warren: Gotcha. Yeah.
Justin Warren: I see.
David: So just before we click on anything. If you scroll up just a bit.
David: And yeah, I think it's really cool that you have kind of both
David: the previous version. And like this version to kind of think about
David: the other big change. I'm not sure if you noticed it was that we actually removed description
David: from the updated.
David: A proposed version.
Justin Warren: I didn't notice it.
Justin Warren: Yeah. And I think it's because I think I mentioned it the 1st time, though
Justin Warren: I asked when I was doing it on my own. I guess I guess I assumed it was a
Justin Warren: required field. So that's why I put something in.
Justin Warren: But I don't think it's necessary, so I think it's a good thing that it's
Justin Warren: it's removed.
Justin Warren: I think the event name, usually the name can help people distinguish
Justin Warren: what each funnel is, so.
David: Yeah.
David: we did keep alt text.
David: oh.
Justin Warren: This is different.
Justin Warren: Yeah, they have.
David: Yeah, yeah.
David: So
David: yeah, just feel free to go through the rest of the process and kind of coming back to the bottom here. I'm not sure if you've found yourself in this similar like with the similar buttons. But what's the difference between save and select and save and insert.
Justin Warren: Question.
Justin Warren: I assume they're the same.
Justin Warren: I would assume they're the same. So.
David: Okay.
Justin Warren: Both are probably not needed.
Justin Warren: I have to sit, save and answer it. Okay.
Justin Warren: just do the description menu down.
Justin Warren: Okay, yeah. I see the differences now.
David: Yeah. So now that you had a little bit more of a compare contrast, experience, is there anything
David: else about the proposed updated version that
David: you like you dislike
Justin Warren: No, I I definitely like
Justin Warren: that. If 7, 2 is the only ratio that it
Justin Warren: forces you into it, and it makes you choose.
Justin Warren: You know, you can crop based on that ratio.
Justin Warren: and I think
Justin Warren: getting rid of the description
Justin Warren: just enough. It's a it's good. It's saves time
Justin Warren: rather than trying to come up with a description.
Justin Warren: So yeah, those
Justin Warren: those 2 aspects stand out
Justin Warren: scars.
David: And are there any additional improvements you'd like to see in that proposed version anything else you'd like?
David: Add to it
David: to make it more
David: efficient, faster for you.
Justin Warren: See that one.
Justin Warren: I can't think of anything else. I'll make it
Justin Warren: faster.
Justin Warren: I don't know if the if you can
Justin Warren: like, when you look
Justin Warren: the proposed aspect ratio.
Justin Warren: like, you know, unless you slide it, you know, up or down.
Justin Warren: if it
Justin Warren: to choose the best.
Justin Warren: what what the computer thinks the best.
David: Okay.
Justin Warren: Part of the image for you that that'd be nice. I don't know.
David: That would be nice. Yeah, maybe.
Justin Warren: I like technology. But
Justin Warren: if it's like a recommended aspect, and then, you know, if you didn't like that, you could check
Justin Warren: if it didn't get that
Justin Warren: that we.
David: And that would save you some time. I see. I see that that's great.
David: very great. Okay, so
David: overall. And let's go ahead and
David: click back to that proposed flow version. One more time.
David: So would you say, with which
David: flow would you prefer the proposed flow or the the way. It is right now.
Justin Warren: And proposed.
David: Okay? And yeah, we kind of went through all of those things. But
David: is there anything else, you know that you'd like to like highlight some things that you really absolutely like. If we if we only had to do one thing to change it.
Justin Warren: It'd be the
Justin Warren: the part where you can only choose. 7. The 7 2 aspect.
David: Yeah.
David: great.
David: So in our last few minutes.
David: is there anything in the current Cms
David: that you feel is missing?
David: And this is beyond, you know, just events, specifically just big picture.
David: Anything that you feel is missing.
Justin Warren: Yeah, the
Justin Warren: I would like to say, flexibility with the size
Justin Warren: of the photos or with the aspect ratios. If there's some more flexibility with that.
David: More flexibility with it.
Justin Warren: Yeah, if there can be
Justin Warren: perhaps different.
Justin Warren: he doesn't. If there could be another aspect ratio.
David: Color. Okay, got it, got it.
David: And are there
David: any types of information that you find yourself needing to communicate to veterans and beneficiary populations
David: that you're currently unable to do.
Justin Warren: Oh, I may add to the previous question and the option
Justin Warren: for more than one photo.
David: More than one photo.
Justin Warren: So like, maybe we have a
Justin Warren: a title image that shows up, you know, before you click the event. Within the event you can add
Justin Warren: more follows.
Justin Warren: As far as what's missing from the Cms
Justin Warren: definitely, it doesn't have to be about investment by anything.
David: It doesn't have to be about events. It can be about literally anything in your daily cms. Drupal flow.
Justin Warren: Gotcha. I'd like to see more
Justin Warren: using more than one image for stories.
David: And.
Justin Warren: Yeah. That's why
Justin Warren: that's a good.
David: Yeah, you you mentioned earlier. Sometimes you'll be sent, you know, 4 or 5 images for a campaign. Are you able to upload all the images you want? Or are you making the call of which to add.
Justin Warren: You're somewhat limited
Justin Warren: with the with the campaign landing page on certain sections, I think, with
Justin Warren: depending on the section you choose, you can upload more than one, but
Justin Warren: I know with like
Justin Warren: you have the hero image, and then you have.
David: Got it.
Justin Warren: Other sections where it's just it. It limits you.
Justin Warren: as far as
Justin Warren: I mean the amount of pictures you get.
Justin Warren: and then some of the information how you put it in is also limited.
David: Yeah. And my, my last question for you, is there any type of information
David: you know we talked about like uploading images. But are there any other
David: aspects of your day to day workflow that
David: are a little more difficult than you think they should be.
Justin Warren: I would, say
Justin Warren: I,
Justin Warren: and maybe it's cause I don't know most efficient way. But when I'm looking for something that I'm working on.
Justin Warren: I'll wait.
Justin Warren: I kind of have to go through
Justin Warren: like content. I usually do like.
Justin Warren: Wow shall kinda
Justin Warren: there's something I'm trying to edit that
Justin Warren: I usually start
Justin Warren: here.
Justin Warren: and then I'll like search for it.
Justin Warren: I'll be like, Okay, I'm with the campaign landing page.
Justin Warren: and then I'll just search for it, and if I, since I know the name.
Justin Warren: find it.
Justin Warren: and you know and then I can get to it there
Justin Warren: if there's like. I don't know if there's an easier way to like find
Justin Warren: things that I'm working on or just worked on.
David: Yeah, you're mostly sentinel. You're mercy.
Justin Warren: Then in less steps.
David: Yeah, it's no, I don't have to do that.
Justin Warren: Yeah, I don't know. That's the because I have access to a lot of stuff, and I have to do it that way, or what. But
Justin Warren: that's usually how I find stuff I'm trying to work on.
David: Gotcha.
David: Yeah. Well, thank you so much for sharing that I will make sure. I mean, we have some great observers and notetakers on here, too, but we're all going to make sure that that's heard. And we're we're writing that down now.
David: I do have a couple other questions from Michelle and Amanda.
David: I can
David: go through them. And then also, yeah, Michelle, Amanda feel free to pop in to give additional context. If there's anything else you'd like to ask
David: I'm wondering how often you upload the image first, st and then immediately use them versus uploading one in one session and returning to use it later.
Justin Warren: It's usually immediately.
David: It's usually immediately
David: got it. So if you're uploading an image, it is you're you're going through the whole process at that time.
Justin Warren: Yeah.
David: Okay, great
David: and then, is there any feedback that you've heard from other people around uploading images?
David: Have you?
David: Yeah. Has that ever come up. Are there other things that you know people
David: think about it?
Justin Warren: It has come up. I'm trying to remember also said
Justin Warren: I think it had to do with the cropping.
David: With the cropping.
Justin Warren: Well, and I'm not sure it's because they were trying to.
Justin Warren: Maybe like the advantage
Justin Warren: it it only allows one aspect, but it gives you multiple options.
Justin Warren: or if the propping was too restrictive in.
Justin Warren: they didn't, their photo didn't fit the particular aspect.
Justin Warren: So I think
Justin Warren: that's what frustrated people
Justin Warren: that I've heard that I, if I can remember correctly that that frustrated additive.
David: Gotcha.
David: Great!
David: Do you have any questions for me?
David: No need. But I just wanted to open it up for you.
Justin Warren: No, no, I don't have anything, nothing.
David: Great, great. Well, we are really, we really appreciate you taking the time to share your thoughts.
David: With us today, your feedback is so helpful as we continue to make Viagov better for veterans, for people like yourself to make that information more accessible. So again, thank you so much for taking the time to chat with us today. Really do appreciate it. And
David: yeah, hopefully, some of your some of what we talked about you'll see in, in the, in, the, in the future, so.
Justin Warren: But for.
David: Open up.
David: great.
Michelle: Justin, yeah.
Justin Warren: Have a good day.
David: You too.